foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and the
political commentator Benedict Spence
Susie will be joining us and they will
both be with us until from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on at some of those front pages for you
now
the eye says inflation is expected to
drop significantly next week so energy
bills will do the same
according to the mail consumers can
expect to save 450 pounds a year on
average
the express has the simple headline
energy bills to Tumble
but the chancellor Jeremy Hunt strikes a
less optimistic note in the telegraph
where he writes that the UK risks
talking itself into economic decline
meanwhile the financial times looks at
the impact of people turning to risky
credit options in tough Economic Times
the guardian reports that some private
GPS in Harley Street in central London
are charging as much as 550 pounds an
hour for consultations
the times leads with a letter written to
the paper by the Association of school
and college leaders describing
artificial intelligence as a clear and
present danger to education
The Mirror Has a story concerning the
serial killer rose West
and the star MOX Rishi sunak as it
reports his personal net worth has
shrunk if that's the right word to only
529 million pounds
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and Benedict Spence to
take us through the papers you are there
Susie welcome
you've been there the whole time
right let's crack on then we'll start
with the eye and they're reporting that
inflation is due to drop next week some
much needed relief there Benedict
well absolutely as you say it's it's a
relief for families across the country
uh the eye is reporting uh that they
could drop by approximately uh household
bills could drop by approximately 450
pounds uh which will come as a sort of
great relief to many people
um and the reasons given for this is
because of the changing nature of the
energy supplies in Europe
um one of the things you know of course
everybody knows when the invasion of
Ukraine by Russia started uh oil and gas
was effectively weaponized by Russia and
then you had the sanctions from Western
Nations placed on Russia but actually
what has happened is uh Nations around
the world have effectively just
redverted their supply chains
um we've sought energy from other places
also it must be said Russia has managed
to circumvent a lot of the sanctions on
it by simply selling its oil and gas to
India which is then sold it back on to
us and other places as well so sanctions
haven't really worked in that sense but
the energy prices are coming down
um that is not to say that we're out of
the woods yet it also says that
inflation is set to drop below 10 that
is true but food prices are still
broadly up and that's as a knock-on
effect from the cost of energy last year
and the cost on for things like
fertilizer last year because of course
it takes a little bit more time for food
products to get from the farm to your
table but this is something that I'm
sure Rishi sunak will welcome seeing as
I suspect a lot of the future of his
Premiership if it has a future rests on
whether or not people feel demonstrably
poorer at the end of uh Parliament than
they did at the beginning yes this is
the I am pointing to the fact the energy
cap is forecast to fall 18 so the
typical bill will drop to about
2053 pounds from 2000 to 500 that's a
significant fall isn't it
Susie oh is it me yes yes it is a
significant fall but of course it is
still much much much much much much much
much more than it was
um when this all started the average
Energy bill was about a thousand or
twelve hundred pounds so saying it's now
merely two grand a year to heat your
home and fuel it and everything else is
still a massive rise and something that
lots of people cannot afford to pay it
is better that it is coming down of
course it is
um but remember as well it's uh all the
things that Benedict has pointed out
that um Russia and India have been
finding a way to get around sanctions
okay and that's partly why some of the
prices have come down and also the fact
that it's summer the fact we've had a
mild winter the demand has not been as
high as it could have been and after we
go through this summer period there's
going to be another
um decision about the price cap which
will be in October just as we head into
winter now they do think that's going to
be about 2 000 pounds when we get to it
but of course we then face the
possibility of a of a cold winter rather
than Mars one is the one we've just had
and when people it's all great to say
that inflation's falling and marvelous
but it's still prices are still going up
so if something cost you 10 pounds last
year it probably cost you about 11
pounds this year it may cost you a lot
more than that 20 the 12 or 13 pounds if
you're buying food but generally
speaking everything's about 10 more
expensive than it was because inflation
is still there but it's just going up
less fast than it was it's dropped below
10 now but that's still it's it's nine
point something percent and that means
that you know next week the prices are
still going to be another growing up
again by almost 10 it's coming down and
that's good and that you know the
government will be happy to have see
these kind of prices as should we be all
be but it is not by any means
um cash in our pockets and in fact one
of these stories is saying that uh from
um uh an Insight company that's analyz
the energy prices and so on you're
saying we're not going to get back to
the kind of prices we pay for energy
before the war in Ukraine until perhaps
the end of the decade until the end of
the 2020s and that this is these are the
kind of prices we're going to have to
expect to pay for another
seven eight years maybe and remember
there are pensioners who um who turned
off their heating this year because they
couldn't afford to run it and if they
can't afford to run it at these prices
when they are subsidized by government
and we've got this price Gap and
everything and this is the kind of price
it's going to stay at then it's by no
means really good news for everybody but
the male reporting um that next week
official figures are set to show
inflation is back below the 10 that the
first time since last summer but but do
you agree with Susie that these stats
and figures are academic really when
people are going to be still facing the
issues that they have been
I wouldn't say that they're academic in
the sense that they are going people
will over the course of the next 18
months see a definitive change not as
much of a change as going back to the
way things were before but they will
notice that things ease up slightly but
I think what Susie does touch upon there
about how potentially we'll be paying
inflated prices uh for the next six
seven years or so is very curious
because many people including this
government I think were caught slightly
unaware by the war in Ukraine and the
knock-on effects that it would have they
were certainly caught
um unprepared by the pandemic and the
knock-on effects that it had and what I
would like to say is if we're going to
sort of future proof is that awful word
that they use ourselves for the future
is look at our supply chains look at our
energy sources look at things like where
we Source our food and say this is the
wake-up call that the country really
needs that you cannot simply leave
yourself open to the headwinds of what
goes on in the rest of the world the
country actually does have the capacity
to invest in energy be be it fossil
fuels be it nuclear be it renewable it
doesn't actually matter which one it can
do all three or it can focus on one or a
combination of two it has the resources
to do that and to secure its own Energy
Future as it does with things like food
production we have simply chosen not to
do that because it was more financially
expedient to do so up to now but the
nature of the world is changing the
nature of geopolitics is changing it now
would be the time for the government be
it this government or the incoming labor
government to say we are going to try to
secure ourselves against these kind of
shocks in the future you know be that
sort of trusting in the private sector
or massive state-led incentives I don't
really care which one it is a government
needs to take the ram by the horns and
say this is not something that we can
allow to keep on happening
I mean across the paper Susie um seem to
be saying that the cost of Boone crisis
is nearing an end
um would you agree with that should
people be cheered by that
look it's good that prices are going to
come down no one can possibly argue with
that but this is by no means coming to
an end and anyone who says that it is is
just repeating stuff blindly
um that they're being fed them by the
government or something because the cost
of living crisis is still very much
there inflation still exists prices are
still going up by almost 10 month on
month
um and it is already unlivable and
unaffordable for many many people there
are
families who have two jobs who have got
two decent jobs who are having to cut
back and who do not have the money that
they had last year to do all the things
that they want to do and who are
actually struggling there are people
undergoing relationship strain and
mental health strains there are more
people off long-term sick than ever
before because of the pandemic because
of the pressures that we're all under at
the moment
um I was looking at something today and
in the 13 years of of Tory government
that we've had
um the poor are worse off they've lost
about 700 pounds because of benefit cuts
that have come in under austerity since
2010 but the richest part of society are
also about 600 pound out of pocket every
year so you know everyone is a bit worse
off than they have been some of them
significantly so and it is by no means
you know just because inflation has gone
under the magic figure of 10 doesn't
mean that suddenly everyone's you know
in Clover and skipping about the street
and thinking hello it's lobster for tea
that's just not happening for local
people in this country and I think we
need to bear that in mind the Daily
Express pointing to experts predicting
that gas and electricity charges will
tumble in July and they're also saying
that positive signs that bills will ease
even more later in the year as wholesale
prices for gas across Europe return to
the levels seen before that the war in
in Ukraine so actually predicting quite
a significant uh reduction in people's
everyday uh costs there Benedict
that's yeah that's certainly true but
again I would say that this is we do
need to Bear In Mind Of course that it
is the summer and on the one hand I
think Susie's right we did have a mild
winter although it was slightly more
elongated slightly more drawn out than I
think many people would have liked uh
but yeah we will come again to that
moment next winter where we do have to
decide whether or not it's going to be
uh sticking the gas on early or going
out and buying woolly jumpers as
everybody was advised to do uh so again
it's one of those tricky situations
where I think a lot of people might be
breathing a sigh of relief
um and going oh thank heavens my bills
are going to come down but they're also
going to be thinking what if they do go
back up again next winter what if we
have a particularly bad winter do I
actually have the funds to be putting
money aside now to be preparing for that
situation and again I am going to step
back and say look at the broader
geopolitical situation if these prices
are coming down that's as a recognition
of the fact that Russia has managed to
get its supplies out to who it wants to
sell to so just broadly speaking it's
not all necessarily positive news on
that front but for the consumer for the
summer yeah right they're not going to
be using so much cash indeed let's have
a look at the this story in the guardian
and Susie take us into this with them
patience paying 550 pounds for an hour's
consultation with with private GPS
does that sound exorbitable
it sounds exorbitant for just about
anything short of kidney surgery to me
um I think that you know the the fact
that people are finding more difficult
to see GPS and find it more difficult to
get appointments because there's a
massive shortage of GPS despite the fact
that the conservatives promise they
would have another 6 000 in the system
by now and they haven't at all
um and there is even talk about some GPS
going out on strike for goodness sake
joining the rest of the NHS means that
there are more people who can afford it
who are going to go and have a private
GP appointment when they need one
um which is strange because then your
entire Health Care kind of comes out of
the NHS system and is all in the in the
private system so you can't like you can
go and get treated in a NHS Hospital
sometimes afterwards although sometimes
you can but there are growing numbers
the guardian says of people that are
signing up to these private services and
some of them are charging 550 pounds but
for that you do get a GP for a full hour
which I don't think anybody's ever
actually seen their GP for a full hour
at any point in their lives unless
something's gone drastically wrong
during your appointment but it's 275
pounds for 30 minutes and they'll do a
house call for 500 pounds now bear in
mind if you think all this is a
ridiculous sum to pay and who would want
to speak to their GP for for a whole
hour I mean what how much is wrong with
you that you could go on for an hour so
again if you if you've got that many
problems you probably need a consultant
surgeon rather than a GP because there's
more going on there
um but this is the kind of uh health
treatment that the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak has admitted that he has he has
private GP appointments so he gets to
enjoy this kind of luxury of sitting
down having a nice gasp with his his GP
for an hour but it's frustrating that
for people though who can't get in to
see their GP
um but can see that these services are
available at a cost that they they
simply can't meet
uh deeply frustrating for the
overwhelming majority of the public who
don't use private Services
um we all know that this isn't new and I
think that it will take again I'm always
saying this it's going to take a brave
government to address the issue at hand
and this particular issue now is NHS
reform we need to be able to put enough
money into the services we need to make
it more efficient we also need to find a
way of making it more attractive for
doctors and nurses to stay in the
profession and of course we need to open
it up to more people to train in the
first place I don't think that that's uh
new but I do think actually that this
story is being a little bit a little bit
cheeky because it's not actually giving
us numbers how many more people are
going to see these private doctors for
exorbitant amounts and then it submits
that it's case study in this incidence
is Harley Street in London which has
always been The Preserve of private GPS
and private surgeons for the super rich
and the famous so I I would like to see
something more on the actual numbers
whether or not there has been a massive
sort of influx of people to Harley
Street um whether or not this is being
borne out elsewhere but I think that
this is this is the sort of thing that
we all know has been going on long
before this particular episode of the
NHS crisis came along that the wealthy
can always afford the best medical
health indeed that the rest of us just
can't